hi I'm Seth McFarland and I'm shooting
gq's men at the year here at this
massive very ornate residence bigger
Diva Ted or Peter Griffin you're really
asking the hard-hitting questions aren't
you probably Peter cuz he's been around
longer he can demand a little more money
most cliched Hollywood moment in my
career I think I once shook hands with K
Kalin while in a strip club at a
bachelor party my favorite a host of all
time would have to be Johnny Carson how
is it that I am so busy and look so
rested uh I'm wearing about a pound of
makeup who would be in the Rat Pack to I
don't know that anybody today is cool
enough to be in the Rat Pack I think
we're all too squinty in
hipster 2012 Man of the Year gosh for me
personally uh Neil degrass
Tyson